a plane crash that killed four Americans
is under investigation in Honduras it's
the second deadly crash involving u.s.
tourists in just a week the plane was
leaving Roatan island when it crashed on
Saturday CBS this morning investigative
correspondent and a Werner is here with
more ana good morning good morning Tony
the crash happened around 2 o'clock
local time shortly after the u.s.
registered plane left the Rowett on
airport military rescue crews arrived at
the scene within minutes recovering four
bodies from the debris of the
single-engine plane a fifth person was
taken at the hospital but died hours
later Honduran government officials say
American passengers Frederic - Pelle
Anthony dubler Robert Miller and Bradley
post died in the crash along with the
Canadian pilot Patrick Forsyth who
worked in the Honduran tourism industry
a local paper la princess says this was
the last photo of the group took before
the crash Saturday's incident comes the
same week that six people were killed
and 10 more injured when two sightseeing
planes crashed midair near Ketchikan
Alaska five of the victims were
passengers from a Princess cruise ship
investigators haven't released details
on what caused this weekend's crash Gale
o janna hard to see that last photo
thank you very much